[Applause]
okay
um so this uh presentation is um you
know on behalf of women taking makers uh
Seattle and I'm so happy to be here and
what we are going to do is we are going
to go through the the mic
methodology for Six Sigma projects and
I'm a I'm eloisa Elias and and I work
for the manufacturing industry for
almost nine years and
I developed many many Six Sigma projects
and we did savings to the thousands
hundreds of thousands of dollars
and just as a context um
right now more than half of the total
542 companies they are implementing 16
methodology
in their processes
and you everybody hears about a lean Six
Sigma and different kinds of names all
of them are the same like as a Six Sigma
project and
and what um the reason I wanted to
provide this perspective is because is
how to introduce the sexism methodology
with data science how how you that you
are an expert in as a data scientist can
combine the two the methodology with all
your your statistical knowledge and your
machine learning knowledge and and make
Six Sigma projects for your companies
and right now we are going to make a
recording pause
because I'm going to show you a very
brief video regarding how
um
I see it as a Six Sigma project
and
think
[Music]
recording
foreign
[Music]
this was a very fun video that I found
that where you have the process owner
and doing the whole work the the
following the the recommendation from
the Six Sigma expert and at the end a
Six Sigma project uh you uh the Six
Sigma expert
I give advice to the process owners so
they can Implement
controls to to all the improvements that
you do through the Six Sigma methodology
and now we continue their recording
and so what is Six Sigma is the degree
of variation in a process
and in Six Sigma we focus in and measure
the defects and the variational of our
processes
so we can create projects for continuous
Improvement
and the goal is to minimize variation
and to Center the process
and the Six Sigma
um requires that the mic methodology
which means Define measure analyze
improve and control
and we
we the main reason that we create the
sigma methodology is to
to measure and quantify a profits
capability
the the process capability
usually we call it CPK
and it is how Center is your process and
how within the specification the
manufacturing specification is your
process is and we study we we we
do at Six Sigma project by using data in
in and as as stratified sampling
in order to predict a
and the the goal of the project or what
we defined at the beginning of the
project
and just for everybody to have a
perspective
in here on the left side we have the
sigma for for any kind of project we can
we we are able to quantify the six the
sixth month the six months
so when we talk about Six Sigma we talk
about that we are going to have 3.4
defect per part per Millions so that is
huge manufactory
we we always try to achieve which is not
easy and in my experience Six Sigma
the process once you measure the process
I'm sorry once you you measure
you are in the measured stage of the mic
methodology
the process with with time is going to
move
1.5 standard deviation
this is a well-known date
data point for us
um in Six Sigma
um
and as a reference it would be
and 99 good of manufacturing
Goods would be that we have atristic map
process
and it would mean it would be in the
thousands of defects
per million spread products produced
so if we have a Six Sigma process with
the same
um the same in the same area
we only have we got from thousands of
defects to only
two two
digits in this case maximum
of defect
so how do do we combine segment data
science
so for this um presentation
I'm going to take you from the
comparison from the mic the mic
methodology to the to the
the the methodology that we use in data
science which is uh the crisp DM
and
just uh some for your information and
the demike methodology was created by
Chrysler Ford and General Motors and the
America America American Association for
quality
I think that that is the name I I forgot
the precise name and the crisp DM was
also created in part with Chrysler
Daimler Chrysler
so they they overlap a lot
from from my perspective I believe they
overlap a lot a lot just
um
I'm going to uh
uh tell you about an example that would
be uh if a company wants to predict
customer churn which is a task that we
as a data scientist we are asked very
commonly
uh we as a data scientist we go uh
immediately to check out the possible
algorithm that we can use to fit the
data and there are Six Sigma expert what
we'll do is to analyze the data and
measure them and make sure that the data
is under control and within a
specification
so for this presentation I created a Six
Sigma roadmap map for you and I'm going
to have some copies if you want to grab
one copy so you can create your six Six
Sigma projects and your and your
workplace
and I am also posting this document into
my GitHub
so we are going to go from Define
measure analyze
um
roadmap to improve control and we are
going to go uh
step
um
section by section and comparing
um a Six Sigma in manufacturing how it's
implemented with a data science points
so in the defined
stage what we do is we really try to
identify what is important for the
customer for us our priority is our
customer internal or external and for
this we use
um in Six Sigma we start with Pareto
charge
and input up output diagrams and trees
and use classes statistics measures to
to just visually visualize
uh the current perspective of the
process
so we can have I start having asking
questions about what is important for
the customer what is the object object
objective of the of the of the project
and everything has to aligned at the end
with the business major business
strategy
and for this what we have is as an
output is an statement of work where we
defined um the goal of the of the Six
Sigma project and
we we create uh just a draft of the
project plan which of some graph and
Matrix
and the comparison for the defined stage
would be for data scientists for a Six
Sigma project you use 35
samples that were taken stratified in a
stratified way and for data science we
use millions of data points so it's a
huge difference to go from 35 data
points to Millions
so in data science we also in machine
learning we use a lot of data mining
visualization but but all of these
points are covering the same point the
same theme that we went in defined we
want to just to have a perspective of
what is going to be the project
objective and what is going to be a
clear goal for the whole team
sorry
then we go from Define we go to measure
in the second stage of the Asic Sigma
project and for for this stage what we
do is now to get metrics of the current
status of the whole process
so just just to realize
um
we are not doing in in measurement we
are not trying to do predictions we are
not trying to to figure out where the
the data going we just want to have a
photo of what is currently happening in
the process
and
so for this
um we read the output would be that we
we now with the data we redefined the
the project and statement and we value
we have to validate the measurement
system that is something
oh
can you see
which one
oh okay
ah thank you
oh
okay
and in here we all we have to something
different different that I noticed uh
from my field in manufacturing to now to
data science is that in manufacture
manufacturing you have to validate your
data you have to be sure that the the
features the parameters that you are
going to utilize in order to do
prediction in your Six Sigma project
they need to be centered they need to
have good capability that means that
what we are measuring it has to be
within the specification and hopefully
you have uh that that
[Music]
um
that's that feature that you are
measuring hopefully it would be above
three sigmas
and our recommendation from the
manufacturing industry is this book this
is a great guide for you to to
validate your your
measure you measure stage
and from the data science perspective we
do we do we check our data with
cross-validation with m
a e and F1 scores something that you can
utilize
and for the analyze stage
now in here we have all our features on
under control we validate that those
features are are good data that that we
can utilize all the data that we have
and now we start
um validating from all the from the
problems that we Define in at the
beginning of the project we start
um
selecting those from those features what
are the features who really impact our
our the goal our end call
so
for the analyze um
we usually from all the variables that
we selected we we utilize
um
like a design of of
this design of experiment in order to
validate those variables that they they
are they are
affecting affecting
the my my why which is the object
objective of the project
and now in it would be for
for from the data science perspective it
would be when we start doing now the
regression models or any kind of machine
learning model and start seeing
predictions and start testing which of
the of our variables are affecting our
end goal
and now uh for any improve in the
improved stage now we from those data
features that we already validated we
just take decisions as a group with the
process
um with the process owner and the Six
Sigma team
and then you implement those
improvements into the process
for this usually what we have a in
manufacturing you you validate your
improvement with three months of data
which is a long time for us in in from
the data science perspective
and in the
analogy for data science would be that
when we do Improvement we refine our
parameters we create new data we we
Implement actions
according to our predictions
and at the end we have the control
um
which is uh how we maintain everything
that we have implemented and into our
processes
and for this we
we provide a statistical
[Music]
um
it's a statistical graph and
measurements of the CPK of the process
and in Implement controls into the
process but
we need to
to figure out if the controls are being
in place so we extend this another
usually one month
and we revisit it again a year after for
manufacturing and we check out if we can
transfer the knowledge to another area
and for data science it's something more
fast that we implement we could affect
or Implement new kpi or implemented in
the r dashboards
so the takeaways from this presentation
would be the
the that Six Sigma is a methodology to
improve business a business process
and we need to have all everything that
we are
measuring and we know that we are all
the variables that we are using in order
to make prediction they need to be under
control and they have to have good CPK
which is everything has to be within the
specifications and we we mainly
are are focusing in our customers
so
right now machine learning a
an AI
we we try to be more efficient and
faster but I I believe from my
perspective and it has worked on some
projects that the following this Six
Sigma methodology provide you uh from my
perspective a faster way to to check out
if you are going to have a good
prediction or a good goal at the end so
it it would be an improvement of the way
you you you you you
currently are using um
you data science models
just it would be like another kind of
process
and with that I'm finished and I'm going
to post um
this document that I created and please
any questions
[Applause]
um